à
m
j'ai marché à contre-courant j'aime la
difficulté
partir d'une page blanche en se disant
je veux faire voler un bateau c'est
peut-être l'histoire d'une vie
l'hydroptère le bateau volant est
devenue en 2009 l'engin voile le plus
rapide du monde en battant deux records
de vitesse en faisant des pointes à plus
de 100 kilomètres heure
c'est un type extraordinaire mais sans
lui bon le bateau ça serait qu'une idée
jamais existé il ya des moments où alain
rosie mais ça va pas quoi il n'est quand
même pas tout à fait comme nous malgré
les échecs malgré les difficultés il a
toujours poursuivi
la durée la constance de l'énergie je
sais pas comment il est foutu dans sa
tête mais c'est clair que c'est pas
commun alain thébault est une moderne
incarnation du pionnier il a passé une
vie d'homme à faire aboutir un rêve
celui de faire voler un bateau de 5
tonnes à grande vitesse à la seule force
du vent et il a réussi
hop hop et r
rosich
non à présent
dans l'air assez plus humide donc là on
va créer 300 personnes on est l'otage
sur les flotteurs qui se re mettre 50 au
dessus du lot et uniquement sur les
trois plans chanteur qui soulève le mato
divine qui après pas louper titrisés
hall
awa fall of the board
attention
non non non
voilà allez la terrasse confie donc
aussi parce que je pense que tous les
bateaux heureusement je vois ça super
c'est vraiment un truc extraordinaire ce
bateau et la passion qui va avec parce
que moi j'ai assisté aux premiers vols
concorde avec les émotions dans l'ordre
et les premiers volontaires fait pas les
premiers mais les vrais vols docteur
avec la même émotion a d'ailleurs versé
dans le gène que tu as essayé de faire
il est en train de se tordre l'intérieur
qu'on veut toile internet et boyaux quoi
et c'est une aventure extraordinaire les
deux et moi je mène les dons parlait
bien sûr les moyens étaient pas les
mêmes bien sûr l'hydroptère c'est par un
concours disponible en mai du premier
résultat c'est pareil
de même passion des gens vont travailler
dessus et le même impressionne de
critiquer quand même extraordinaire de
beauté dans son dans son volet
alain thébault est un enfant du
guilvinec un port de pêche situé tout au
bout de la bretagne
mais au guilvinec alain thébault
s'ennuyait sauf les jours ou après
l'école il cavale est jusqu'au port
avec mon coussin jean-luc quiniou nous
avions un canot pneumatique jaune et
bleu et nous avions surfer les vagues
des chalutiers qui rend dans ce port du
guilvinec et ça gêne est en fait le
canot pneumatique cola cola la pente et
donc ca généré une frustration énorme
d'envoyer les mouettes autour on se
disait mais je me suis dit un jour je
volerais au port de pêche
c'est pas le métier de pêcheur ni l'air
marin qui l'attirait
à quoi rêvent les enfants du bord de mer
c'est parfois un grand mystère
d'où viennent les envies comment
naissent les destinées au fond
l'histoire de l'hydroptère doit beaucoup
aux mouettes du deal visniec
c'est un cheminement difficile long
complexe et contre vents et marées
aujourd'hui notre bateau vol le canot
pneumatique si les deux néo surf à
pleine vitesse
aujourd'hui nous sommes 1 55 noeuds avec
des pointes à 200 à l'heure c'est
quelque chose de fascinant
sinon c'est le mélange de deux mondes
d'un moment est enterré ici avec les
issues d'une famille de pêcheurs mon
papa réparer des avions je les ai peu
connu tous les deux mais mais ce rêve a
pris forme sur les vagues et ce qu'est
du guilvinec
pour faire voler un bateau il faut
d'abord un rêve d'enfant mais ce que ne
savent pas les enfants c'est que parfois
les adultes ont les mêmes rêves en 1976
eric tabarly essayait de faire voler une
maquette de six mètres qui reposait sur
des folles et qui avait navigué le temps
d'un été
les marins qui ont en tête de faire
voler les bateaux n'étant pas si
nombreux il arrive parfois qu'ils
finissent par se rencontrer en 1984
alain thébault avait passé un été à
dessiner les plans dan hydroptère ils
venaient les montrer à eric tabarly qui
l'attendait chez lui en bretagne
c'est une rencontre puissante avec au
coin de la cheminée sur un banc en bois
avec une présence un charisme et puis
une histoire eric c'est l'histoire des
états pionniers en fait le premier à
avoir cru au bateau qui vole moi je suis
arrivé avec mes plans un peu ridicule
nos qu'eric m'écoute regarde les plans
les commente
et après il me dit miku tu as l'air bien
déterminer si tu le souhaites tu peux
rester à bénodet tu t'occupes de tout
ici ça marche je te prendrai à mes côtés
et il m'a quand même laissé entendre que
ça prendrait du temps
le temps durera dix ans le temps de
commencer par fabriquer une maquette de
la taille d'un jouet que tvo tirs est au
bout d'un fil pour la faire décoller
mm
le temps de construire un petit
hydroptère de six mètres qui volent
s'appuie sur des feuilles et file au
dessus du lot de plus en plus vite
le temps de comprendre que pour qu'un
grand bateau volant voit le jour le
meilleur moyen d'aller voir ce qu'ils
font voler les avions
dassault j'allais rencontrer pour la
première fois au salon du bourget voilà
comme je n'arrivais pas à obtenir de
rendez vous avec monsieur dassault je me
suis dit que le plus simple était
d'exposer ma maquette mon bateau au
milieu des avions salon de
l'aéronautique et ça a marché
je n'ai croisé ainsi que son
vice-président et ils ont décidé de
m'aider en bon vendeur avec le carnet
d'adressés de tabarly persuadé que son
engin naviguerez à la confluence de
l'air et de l'eau taibou réussi à
embarquer dans son aventure les fleurons
de l'industrie aéronautique et des
constructions navales
les grands industriels se sont impliqués
dedans parce que il s'y trouvait sans
doute un apport de leurs propres
technologies de pointe
dassault est intervenue toute
l'industrie aéronautique française est
intervenue avec ses techniciens les plus
pointus ou dassault pour moi c'était
quelque chose que les îles font de beaux
avions puis comme disait marcel vote
marcel dassault le fondateur un un bel
avion est un bon avion
donc on essayait de c'est un beau bateau
disant le temps d'entamer une aventure
technologique avec des ingénieurs comme
philippe perrier filmé chez dassault
poignée d'hommes passionnés qui continue
d'améliorer le quotidien de l'hydroptère
aujourd'hui un jour tu es beau les a
surnommés les pattes et elle est râpé
alors les papes et c'est tout ce qui fit
travaillent bénévolement pour
l'hydroptère qui ont une certaine
expérience en général dans le milieu
aéronautique
ce que grosso modo les papiers ils
viennent soit de l'aérospatiale d'airbus
ou de dassault et qui pour la plupart
sont à la retraite mais c'est pas mon
cas mais je portais quand même
l'hydroptère aînés pour partie si l'on
peut dire dans les maternités
aéronautique de dassault et de
l'aérospatiale dans des usines où
d'ordinaire naissent les avions
et
la province dix ans le temps de
transformer un rêve d'enfant en projet
d'envergure nationale l'hydroptère n'est
pas le con corps et pourtant les
industriels et les politiques ils voient
l'incarnation de l'excellence
technologique comme concorde où le tgv
faire des gens j'ai complètement un
voilier de haute mer
voilà l'objet du défi technologique et
sportif qu'eric tabarly a initié en 1976
dix ans pour que sortent des chantiers
de l'atlantique à saint nazaire 1
hydroptère 18 mètres de long une masse
de cinq tonnes au décollage
un bateau volant
le 1er octobre 1994 est un grand jour
pour la première fois avec à son bord
jean le cam et michel desjoyeaux deux
des meilleurs navigateurs français
l'hydroptère joue avec la crête des
vannes des fiches
il faut d'abord volé de manière stable
avant de voler vite donc maintenant
qu'on a obtenu la stabilité on n'ouvre
le domaine des hautes vitesses à chaque
sortie la sensation de renvoyer
archimède au placard en 600 bateaux nous
ne flotte plus de mes folles
c'est quelque chose qui pour moi était
complètement nouveau début de l'année
le mettre sur le nettoie puissance max
son bord dans le met sous le nez des
cons à la vitesse on cadre un peu le
bateau en abattant lombard sur la
tranche douze ans après leur première
rencontre
l'hydroptère n'est plus une chimère il
est l'aboutissement d'une idée imaginée
par eric tabarly en son temps
concrétisée par alain thébault avait
confiance dans ce marché
et puis comme lui va il s'accroche et
bien il a été vraiment percé ans
un pionnier pourrait facilement passer
pour un casse pieds en raison de son
entêtement
les centaines a cité comme offrait le
pionnier pour résister aux coups durs au
vent mauvais à l'adversité
l'hydroptère a toujours navigué en mer
agitée d'une certaine manière c'est un
miracle que ce projet ne soit pas mort à
plusieurs reprises malgré la casse je me
suis dit que ceux des problèmes
techniques on sort et les résoudre un
jour ou l'autre
il a eu le courage et le mérite d'aller
d'avancer toujours parfois contre vents
et marées c'est par un euphémisme
le 22 juin 1995
l'hydroptère effectué une sortie de
prestige en baie de quiberon avec la
frégate surcouf de la marine nationale
l'hydroptère a belle allure thébault et
son équipage ne manque pas d'ambition
il envisage prochainement de faire
tomber les records à commencer par la
traversée de l'atlantique en quatre
jours au lieu de 7
donc en ce jour d'été
l'avenir de l'hydroptère et bleu comme
le ciel
envolée de
avec environ vingt neuf ans avec une
vitesse stabilisée de l'ordre de 25
noeuds on se rapprocher de la frégate
surcouf
mais tout d'un coup crac
un craquement sinistre comme une
fracture
le bras de liaison bâbord s'est
désintégré parti d'une feuille blanche
les ingénieurs aéronautiques ont
sous-estimé les efforts sur la structure
en carbone qui atteint ce jour là par
endroit 20 tonnes par mètre carré au
lieu des 10 tonnes prévues c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué en avion
l'hydroptère parce que l'hydroptère lisa
wiik à la fois dans l'air et dans l'eau
alors qu'un avion il est uniquement dans
l'air et finalement le la les
caractéristiques de stabilité de
comportement sont beaucoup plus complexe
que celle d'un avion
on est content d'avoir amené le bateau
s'était pas et qui
on est mal mais mal enfin tout est
relatif
enfin je pense qu'il ya des gens quand
on a un cancer des poumons on est
vraiment très mal quand on vient de
casser son bateau et qui finalement il
marche quant à ses biens
on a l'espoir de le voir renaître
au fond la vie de l'hydroptère est
contrastée comme certains jours le ciel
de bretagne
il y à l'ombre et la lumière les succès
les échecs les doutes et les espoirs
l'hydroptère est un projet pionnier
techniquement complexe qui en dix ans va
connaître trois avarie majeure
à certaines périodes comme ça cumule les
ennuis techniques et les soucis
financiers des bosses en tête refusent
les compromis par fierté et par la haute
idée qu'il se fait de l'hydroptère vous
est-il arrivé de vous opposer tous les
deux oui bien sûr eu bien sûr mais c'est
comme ça que ça marche il faut pas
toujours dire oui à tout et où dix ans
nous a tous je m'étais accroché avec
avec le président d'une grande
entreprise qui voulait son logo en gros
sur la voile et avec n'est pas vraiment
les moyens de développer voilà je lui ai
dit monsieur le président en personne
n'est indispensable
et ça s'est mal terminée pour moi je
vivais ensuite dans ma voiture mais
j'étais libre heureusement qu'il est
têtu
je pense que l'hydroptère ne serait pas
là c'est alain thébault était pas têtus
et l'audace c'est aussi de savoir
nourrir sur un quai où vivre dans une
voiture et de refuser refuser quelque
chose qui ne vous paraît pas acceptable
alain thébault a donc dormi sur un banc
vécu un hiver dans sa voiture et il a
fini par se réconcilier avec philippe
camus
dans une vie de pionnier l'hydroptère
est un objet envahissant en fait la vie
d'alain thébault n'a jamais cessé dans
la c de manière intime la trajectoire du
voilier volant c'est une étreinte
passionnel qui fatalement cause quelques
dégâts relationnel à l'eau mais en fait
tu as la trinité sur mer
c'est la désolation à céline est parti
avec les meubles et tous ces bons mais
ça va on met ça va en fait ça fait tout
drôle de voir l'appartement viteos ah
mais ça va pour la vie elle est partie
avec ses meubles moi je n'en ai pas
beaucoup films ont principalement fait
un meuble en carbone et en titane
donc j'aime le bois c'est mon matériau
préféré mais ça ne pose pas de problème
particulier que que les meubles vole
également quelques années auparavant
la mère de ses trois filles étaient
partis hélas sa compagne du moment
s'envoler pour un temps le pôle affectif
est à marée basse
voilà mais la marée basse et jolie aussi
on découvre des choses on découvre des
cailloux on découvre des choses que l'on
ne voit jamais sur soi-même notamment
avec un relief qui est très particulier
enfin j'ai hâte que la marée remonte
tout de même
à bord début 2005
les équipiers sont en combinaison de
survie au cas où
pour ce très bref et 37 d'auteur mais on
peut attaquer
l'objectif sportif c'est de stabiliser
la vitesse que l'on vient de filer à
savoir 37 noeuds sur une traversée de la
manche entre douvres et calais et
blériot ont traversé la manche a cassé
10 avions où nous avons eu que quatre
versions hydroptère et celle ci sera la
bonne le 25 juillet 1909
après bien des déboires l'aviateur louis
blériot réalise la première traversée de
la manche exploits d'un pionnier qui
marque l envol de l'aviation au
détriment des dirigeables
tenez vous
accrochez vous accrochez vous
franchement veille au grain
ok le 9 février 2005
l'hydroptère améliore le temps de
blériot mais c'est anecdotique
ce record n'a aucune valeur sportive
simplement pendant plus d'une demi heure
de traversée
l'hydroptère a tenu une moyenne de 33
noeuds 61 km heure je savais qu'on me
battrai ce record la portée symbolique
pour ont été très importante et je me
suis dit à cette époque si on peut
traverser la manche plus vite que
blériot peut-être qu'un jour on doit
pouvoir faire le tour du monde en moins
de quarante joue enfin moi je suis sûr
j'ai basculé vers le déraisonnable à
partir du record de la manche
à lanzarote aux îles canaries c'est
filmé comme un film de vacances par
l'équipe de l'hydroptère mais l'ambiance
n'est pas à la rigolade ni aux bains de
mer
voilà c'est sans doute l'épisode le plus
noir de l'histoire du bateau volant la
fois où il faillit mourir sur un quai
parti pour traverser l'atlantique
l'hydroptère entamé sa traversée du
désert il manquait cent mille euros pour
amener le bateau en france et le réparer
entre paris et les canaris tu es beau
essayer de sauver un projet à bout de
souffle
nous avons eu un souci technique il ya
quelques mois à 50 milles au nord il y
avait trois mètres de creux bateau
filles et 25 de on a percuté un
globicéphale ou une espèce de grosse
tortue luth de 400 kg donc nous avons
rapatrié la pièce abîmé en france et
airbus puis le cyclone h achevé le
cyclone d'état je suis une de casser le
bateau
c'est triste de le voir comme ça alors
qu'est ce qui est vu dhabi mais on va
faire un petit tour non
il est sérieux l'impact sur l'intrados
est les flotteurs d'employer un trou de
danse et ça les flotteurs et sur la
coque centrale et par l'impact donc on
est resté figé à lanzarote effectivement
tout le monde est effondrée c'était
particulièrement difficile car les deux
acteurs industriels français qui nous
soutenaient à l'époque ds et alstom donc
en se sont arrêtés de nous soutenir
quand on a une difficulté ce type il
faut vendre son appartement et et se
dire que ça va être difficile à titre
familial
mais bon ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
et je dirais que l'argent c'est un outil
en fait pour aller au bout de ses rêves
ça n'est pas une fin en soi
tout
cadeau n'était nous au creux de la vague
en six ans on a encore planté le bateau
sur une baleine lanzarote à fait vrai
comment on va s'en sortir on n'osait
même plus l'appeler les papes et on ne
sait même plus l'appeler browning et
c'est lui qui quelques jours après ma
pelle il en tue croit au père noël tu
j'y ai cru à l'époque et je viens de le
trouver
début 2010 gare de lyon à paris depuis
cinq ans alain thébault fait des allers
retours entre la france et la suisse
parce qu'à genève vit l'homme qui a
sauvé la vie de l'hydroptère
je venais de publier un premier livre
pilote d'un rêve en 2005 est alors un
homme thierry lombard appel est-ce que
je peux humblement vous aider
modestement vous aider c'était vous avez
déjà envoyé deux mails et puis j'ai gdj
aime l'humilité
en fait c'est une approche très très
modeste de tir il en bas thierry lombard
est un homme discret
thierry lombard président la plus
ancienne banque privée de genève fondée
en 1796 thiery lombard aime la peinture
de magritte les histoires de jules verne
et les aventures de tintin tiré lombard
a lu le livre d'alain thébault et son
histoire la toucher qu'est-ce que vous
décidez de faire donner un petit coup de
main donné un petit coup de main
d'appeler alain est de lui poser la
question au fond est-ce que ce rêve qui
s'est un peu écornée arrêté qui est un
peu abîmée sur un qe ii de lanzarote est
ce qu on pourrait essayer de lui
redonner la possibilité de revenir
je pensais que c'était un beau projet je
pensais que c'était un projet qui avait
besoin d'un peu de structures de
compétences d'organisation suis
peut-être mieux est meilleur dans ce
volet là que que dans les volets de
créativité pour moitié s'est pas
vraiment un banquier c'est plutôt un
enfant quand j'ai vu je me suis mis
l'avant l'oeil qui pétille
je sais pas si les banquiers mais en
tout cas il en a pas le pour moi le
banquier c'est pas un personnage comme
eu un personnage un peu de romans un
personnage un grand enfant voilà donc
j'étais très surpris
lors de leur première rencontre
thierry lombard avait emmené alain
thébault dans son château situé à bavois
à côté de lausanne la stabilité en
roulis plus importante et on va dans des
vitesses moyennes
ac je pense qu'on va avoir une bonne
vitesse aussi dans le petit temps ça
c'est vraiment l'inconnu déséquilibre là
je devrais me toi c'est bien comme ça
c'est un petit pas de plus dans une
longue histoire est belle histoire de
record de projets de de rêve de et une
petite petite goutte dans un bel hôtel
nous sommes co pilote de ce rêve est à
deux on va beaucoup plus loin
voilà donc et puis c'est quelque chose
que j'ai envie de partager
j'aime foncièrement cette histoire et
depuis que nos amis suisses sont arrivés
elle a changé de dimension
non seulement en termes d'organisation
mais il ya un mariage de volonté et de
passion
donc je pense qu'il ya une parfaite
complémentarité aussi têtu d'un côté que
de l'autre
et puis très forts ensemble à partir de
2005 tirer lombard n'a pas cessé de
s'investir personnellement dans le
projet de l'hydroptère safer 35 pièces à
faire
on se met ses lignes
soul influence de thierry lombard
l'hydroptère passe un contrat de
partenariat avec le pfl l'école
polytechnique fédérale de lausanne une
puissance scientifique certains de ses
étudiants et de ces chercheurs vont
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les ingénieurs aéronautiques
les polytechniciens et les marins proche
d'alain thébault se penche sur des
problèmes physiques d'une grande
complexité
à titre d'exemple la pression exercée
sur un fol peut être deux fois plus
élevé que sur une aile d'avion de chasse
aux laboratoires de technologie des
composites
on travaille sur des procédés de
fabrication et d'assemblage
on teste on évalue les efforts qui
affecte l'hydroptère avec des
échantillons de carbone
à 5 tonnes j'ai reçu grâce à chauny 4800
tueur des plus comme ça
il ya des problèmes de couplage hydro
élastique de flexion torsion ça peut
conduire à la perte des appendices
notamment le gouvernail à 55,2 nous
sommes au delà de 100 à l'heure et j'ai
des phénomènes l'hydrodynamique et les
phénomènes de structures qui peuvent
amener à la perte de cette pièce donc on
perdrait le contrôle du bateau ça peut
c'est potentiellement c'est quand même
très dangereux
donc on est très heureux d'avoir cette
forte dimension scientifique sur
lesquels nous nous appuyons en fait on
leur fait une confiance quasi totale
en suisse aux pays de l'horlogerie de la
précision le rapport au temps d'alain
thébault va s'accélérer l'hydroptère
entre dans une ère nouvelle
à partir de 2007 arrive le temps des
très haute vitesse à la voile
en combinaison jaune en étoffe d eros
approche les hydres opté rien damien
cole grave l'ingénieur françois cazala
anciens véliplanchiste de haut niveau
alain thébault n'a pas le baccalauréat
jean mathieu bourgeon ingénieurs en
hydrodynamique anders bringdal surf les
vagues les plus hautes de la planète en
planche à voile
jacques vincent un pur marin huit tours
du monde
pado
ça génère forcément intéressant c'est un
prototype va à haute vitesse il ya de
l'inconnu ou des réflexes ultrarapide
quoi c'est à cette vitesse là tout se
passe tellement vite
on va vraiment une impression de vitesse
de vibrations et on est c o retient son
souffle
je dirais que le plus difficile c'est de
faire une trajectoire la plus pure
possible
j'admire que je déplace dans le bleu je
ressens tout dans mon bac et carbone les
pilotes avec les tripes les instruments
un temps de retard en fait et je reçois
toutes les informations extérieures les
légats crash d info jacques au ou jérémy
lisent le plan d'eau francs somme
annoncée vitesse jean matelassiers ton
j'étudie n'allait je transforme tout ça
dans le plan horizontal en vitesse max
j'ai plutôt un espèce de stress son
vis-à-vis de la mécanique c'est à dire
que je re vu que la case du bateau parce
que parce que c'est un sport mécanique
et puis que tout est calculé au plus
juste et qu'effectivement on peut casser
des choses pas
nous savions ce jour là je pense que
c'était limite
c'était une mauvaise décision que de
partir à 45 noeuds de vent avec un
bateau surpuissant avec une eau à huit
degrés
et d'en remettre l'aïe a colmaté
casseurs pris par une rafale de vent le
bateau a chaviré bilan humain
heureusement sans gravité
alain thébault eu tout le temps de
méditer cette citation de winston
churchill qui dit que le succès c'est
d'aller d'échec en échec sans perdre son
enthousiasme
ça s'est mal terminée
avez vous pu miner ce jour là non non
non moi je fulmine pas encore quand il
ya des difficultés
la première chose qui était importante
ça va personnes étaient blessées dans le
cadre de ce projet c'était la seule
chose qui m'apportait ensuite on peut se
mettre autour d'une table et essayer de
trouver les bonnes solutions
les belles relations elles sont toujours
tumultueux zh
si je meurs demain tout et tout est
prévu en fait je suis prêt l'engagement
est telle que chacun doit non pas ne pas
avoir peur mais chacun doit mesurer le
risque pris je me souviens de champs
matures mon bras droit qui m'a dit là
c'est chaud mais c'est tout le temps
chaud dans ses gammes de vitesses et
nous sommes face à l'inconnu donc chacun
doit mesurer le risque certain en prix
là ont pris l'initiative de débarquer du
projet parce qu'il ne le sentais pas et
c'est tout à fait respectable je préfère
quelqu'un qui me disent
écoute je ne le sens pas je m'en vais
plutôt que d'avoir à bord quelqu'un qui
ne mesure pas le niveau de risque qui
parfois est élevé
vous pouvez m'aider à mettre la table
pour ma ps3 pas toi je pense tu vas dns
et loomis à neuf victoires pour la
petite la jeune fille
c'est un bon papa mais il est compliqué
parce que il ya le bateau et c'est
compliqué parce que quand il y aller
quand ya beaucoup de vent et ben il doit
partir sur un cheval tu peux aller vite
mais sur un voilier il faut être
raisonnable sur un cheval ce sera tout
de même le cheval en affaires sur le
cheval du monde je suis tranquille ah
ben non moi je vais avoir les pieds qui
touche au match est trompeur j'aime
cette alternance de phases de douceur en
coin du feu avec mes enfants leurs
problèmes
la vraie vie et puis la très haute
vitesse ce monde que peu de personnes
connaissent 7,7 c'est assez curieux donc
c'est pour ça que j'avais choisi le ce
titre pilote d'un rêve mon premier livre
parce que parmi ces pilotes d'un
cauchemar
je pense que les films ne mesure pas
mais en même temps ça serait en fait
remettre ce notre vie dépend des
entièrement du bateau quand même sur le
bateau cassé plus personne ne parlait
tablant surtout surtout on ne m'énerve
pas le bateau cassé il faut que je
trouve de l'argent personnes à hauts
risques quand yves m bon bah je lui ai
dit que ça faisait 20 ans qui
travaillait et il avait toujours un pas
réussi à avoir un record son bateau a
cassé beaucoup de fois mais maintenant
il
il marche bien et peut aller vite alors
c'est bien
automne 2009 en rade d'hyères à côté de
toulon onze hommes à bord escaladent le
mur du temps
à cette époque
l'engin voile le plus rapide au monde
est un kite surf dont le record sur 500
m se situe juste au-dessus de 50 noeuds
80 12 km
pour faire mieux il faut parcourir 500
mètres en moins de 20 secondes
c'est assez pour revoir l'histoire d'une
vie l'émoi du guilvinec
la maquette le bateau qui vole les
avaries le doute les railleries les
ennuis techniques et soucis personnels
l'hydroptère va-t-il réussir
la structure va t'elle tony
51 ou 36 de moyenne sur 500 m 59 17 sur
un mille nautique en deux mois
l'hydroptère fait tomber deux records
des vitesses ordinaire des points tout
de suite 100 km est née une pointe à 102
km heure donc le record absolu de
vitesse à la voile est désormais le
nôtre c'est vraiment une oeuvre
collective fantastique de personnes ont
eu un rôle décisif eric tabarly a cru
avant tout le monde et va donner une
impulsion décisive il m'apparaît dehiba
et d'emma soutenu il m'a porté et aux
manches trébucher thierry lombard à un
banquier suisse m'a dit alain est-ce que
je peux ablement vous aider
eric tabarly thierry lombard on a su
collectivement porter ce bateau cet
oiseau cet oiseau de 7 tonnes qui il
faut décoller dans des accélérations
prodigieuse dépasser 100 km heure c'est
fascinant
j'ai bien double record mondial
c'est qu'on a fait le job
amiral je suis très ému de recevoir
cette distinction aujourd'hui il s'agit
en effet de notre première distinction
et je ne peux non plus haut sans
remercier les femmes et notamment mes
trois filles joséphine héloïse et
victoire avec elle à la montagne
quelques jours avant le report
les enfants nous avons sur les fichiers
météo et des conditions exceptionnelles
puis-je vous laisser toutes les trois
seuls à la montagne dans cet hôtel
pendant look noël mal si papa c'est ta
passion nous savons que tu vas y arriver
en france les enfants
merci ces deux records et cette
distinction sera aussi les vôtres
merci à vous tous
en décembre 2009 place de la concorde à
paris alain thébault reçoit le prix du
chef d'état major de la marine
félicité par jacqueline tabarly
félicité par philippe perrier et les
papés
admiré par ses filles
au début de son aventure
alain thébault avait pour ambition de
naviguer au large et de battre des
records en août mais les années ont
passé
l'hydroptère a juste traversé la manche
est pas encore l'atlantique
faut-il pour autant s'en moquer
aujourd'hui hydroptère et le bateau
l'engin propulsé par les voiles le plus
rapide qui existent au monde
moi je pense que ça suffit pour clouer
le bec à tous les détracteurs et il y en
aura toujours qui se rencontrent parce
qu'ils ont peur d'aller vite parce
qu'ils auront peur de voler parce que
ils ont jamais mis les pieds sur un truc
comme ça
tant pis pour eux parce que c'est
tellement magique qu'il fallait faire
quand on est capable de d'aller contre
les attaques qui appuya voir ce projet
est de garder la tête haute et de
continuer sans juin je dirais que ça
c'est c'est quelque chose de vague de
force il faut des hommes forment ce
genre de situation
préfigure la construction d'un oiseau de
grande envergure qui existent pour
l'instant dans les ordinateurs
trente mètres de long et de large 18
tonnes des feuilles de 10 mètres le tour
du monde en 40 jours en 2013 peut-être
c'est facile et c'est ses concorde aussi
là encore et c'est une aventure où on
allait à la conquête de l'impossible
une folle aventure sans doute mais pas
plus folles finalement que l'idée de
faire voler un bateau il ya 25 ans
d'abord de rêve ultime ça c'est quelque
chose de puissant fait et c'est quelque
chose qu'ils veulent transporter
l'histoire d'alain thébault a débuté
comme dans les contes de feu sa mère
était fille de marin pêcheur son père
réparer des avions entre l'aérien et le
maritime son enfance aurait pu le
transporter bennoo elle fut grise comme
un nuage divers j'étais enfermé puisque
j'étais dans un pensionnat ma maman
était dans un hôpital psychiatrique
donc elle je la voyais assez peu j'ai dû
la voir quatre fois mon papa était en
afrique sur un autre continent donc
c'était c'était une vie j'étais en
partie élevé par ma tante et puis
j'étais pas pour cela trop jeune pour
être en pension avec les garçons donc
j'étais misogyne à l'époque il n'y avait
que des filles partout pour se
structurer on a besoin de ses parents et
à défaut de les avoir il faut créer ses
propres règles donc la seule règle que
j'avais c'était quatre murs et à un
vasistas a qu'un point de ciel bleu de
temps en temps j'avais besoin de changer
d'air j'ai besoin d'une vie plus plus
plus coloré c'était difficile le pays
est rude en fait il suffit de regarder
le diamètre des gouttes depuis assez
fréquente donc j'avais respirait à plus
de liberté je voulais sortir de cet
enfermement
de m